what are we shaking shaking
everything and we've already started the
episode hello everybody my name is marbl
and welcome
back Minecraft we are here Sugar Sugar
suar su su super hot super hey everybody
yeah anyway was that the intro oh no
that's the
intro after all the others shaking yeah
I know that you guys uh some of you guys
like
the oh my God what the hell is this are
you smoking weed
[Laughter]
Mar
yeah I think I swallowed by
uula oh
God
anyway I know that some of you guys like
the uh the really elaborate games and
whatnot but a lot UL swallowing yeah
like aula well my favorite Hometown
sport of South Korea but we um what
we're going to be doing is we're just
going to be shooting the building a
house surviving talk I don't know what
we're oh God I need food I'm going to
die basically this is a fancy way of
saying we have no plan and we wanted to
record more so here we are no beating
Wade here we go can't we just play video
games and then if you watch it that's
fine but if you don't that's also fine
that's basically my entire life this is
for us this is for us yeah you you can
be here if you want what sometimes it's
for the children this is for us I'm
starving Wade shut up let's just if you
die wa you just respawn like 20 feet
away I can't oh my God what's that in
the sky oh what is it oh God where'd it
go what happened I think that's what you
call a I think you had a few too many a
shooting star what the heck Mark I no I
think he's drunk too much tonight hey
here's a chicken Wade you want me to
kill for it please you kill that chicken
I'll kill Youk I would kill for some
some chicken from the sky what B Chev
shut up what' you say Bob some someone
should get wood I've got enough seats
that we can do a farm like let can we
you're right that's how you play
Minecraft it's been so long we do want
to do
that Z's not gonna just give us stuff
this time so we have to
actually I'm getting wood I got wood I'm
getting wood
so many jokes made from this wood I'm g
go and get wood also yeah because it
makes me happy I've had wood all night
why don't you share your wood with us
you want you want a sword fight with my
wood you you want I would appreciate if
you got your wood out and shared it with
us would you like to exchange wood with
me Wade I would love to exchange wood
with you I'm going to take an Axe and
chop your wood up into little wooden
planks and then chop those up into
little wooden sticks
no no okay no not that all right my
Wood's gone down
[Laughter]
now that that ruined everyone wood you
killed hey guys I'm going to put up a
crafting table like done somewhere like
like like right here that that's really
helpful because as you know guys
crafting tables allow you shut
up I'm sorry I was just trying to help
the new Minecraft people he's trying to
channel that one episode we did like 20
or whatever it the episode that no one
lik built a house and no one liked it
for no good reason it was our favorite
episode to make because we were so
sarcastic the entire time and everyone
hated it you
sarcastic Mark was because he like oh
yes Wade my friend I will not what I
said I was you were doing the dickest
yumy have you even seen this episode I
don't know no I I have not seen that
well basically we were doing a thing it
was like a self- reverential meta thing
where we were like let's do it normally
and everyone was like what the
wrong with you guys are you okay did
someone die what's going
on this episode so boring exactly pretty
much like 80% of the comments were like
man you guys suck I can't
believe I watch this
channel this is like normal Minecraft I
know I didn't watch this for normal
Minecraft I don't know I don't get it
but either way get the fact that it was
all a joke yeah whatever though
apparently we're not allowed to make
jokes especially not a they're super
clever and hilarious don't dare make a
joke when I'm here
guys all we do here is make silly voices
and make funny faces let's have another
funny face contest oh people love that
can we do that again fny face cont
everyone go in three two
one no oh my God I think I just split my
lip open ow oh my god really are you
okay ow that hurt a lot
I'm so sorry are we my back yeah we're
done you can stop yummy stop yummy stop
stop yummy yummy stop start having blood
drip from my face because of what I just
did on camera you okay do you need a
break what no I F and we're here because
Bob's
Dying God man this game got so this
chairel got so much worse than you hit
me Mark of a broken lip what sorry what
you hit me
who knew Minecraft would be so apologize
right now no say sorry no you'll regret
it I have an apple I'll hit you with my
my
w
confr gota be more assertive or Mark's
never gonna listen to you yeah exactly
I'm a kind of a douche he's kind of a
bully we should to build like a
neighborhood where we each have our own
house or we building one house let's
build a
neighborhood that that was not that
funny I'm just
I I appreciate the effort but that was
not that funny you laughed I it all
right so where's the where's the spawn
oh here's the crafting table okay legit
building I don't understand what did I
just
miss wait shut up just shut up godam it
God damn it waade yummy gets it yummy
gets it yummy get a few minutes
what all right I'm going to dig in the
dirt let get something I'm just trying
to be nice and build no no you're a
douche you can't do that in this server
guys I'm all alone
dick I hope you D dead whoa whoa yummy
who oh Jes I went a bit yeah who going
to go start collecting Stone okay no I
got it no I got it I'm on
that do it hey guys do you remember the
things from Star
Wars what
bun hair yes Mark that's just
sad oh my gosh there's iron just sitting
out here where oh fine where I am shut
up Bob's not going to share it cuz he's
a Jer yeah Bob's a Jer it's everyone to
Lear to share yeah
exactly what the heck's going on dude oh
God no ladin appeared in my
mind what
no
what F what's going on I don't
understand I'll just leave him be he'll
be back we broke
him I really don't understand Latin
appeared in front of me she just was
there God so she's just is that what
that random terrifying noise is yes she
just showed up I don't know what
happened is she still here ah I can fly
why can't I fly why am I
flying are you flying on purpose or I am
I have fly oh I hope no one takes it
away cuz I'm really high up right now
take it away no don't take it away go to
the ground no
no this is my
favorite I think Mike's dead you guys
want to like all get together and like
bu rebuild something while Mark dies
yeah sure hang out I'll uh I'm still
alive apparently so I got a furnace over
here oh God Mark's next to me get him
away do you not see Latin right there do
you waade look do you do you
not waade I don't see Latin wait are you
kidding me right now no I do not see her
I swear I do not see
Latin who's L I'm missing
out y you're so not hip to what's going
on right somebody else up here and
confirm that Latin is nowhere to be
found right here she's over there in the
trees she's hiding wait she disappeared
what kind of crack did you smoke she
disappeared she I like what's going on
in your head she
gone she's gone you're okay buddy no she
was here I swear that was like a long
time ago Mark the hell are you guys Mark
take medicine ancient history is what
that is hey I lost it you all I'm I
don't know where I am uh please help me
I don't know where where did you
go I went in that direction that doesn't
help me if you're pointing right now it
really doesn't help anyone
way come and get me guys I don't know
where you are I was lost for forever oh
Bob this is where you're digging coming
over here too yeah hey there's a
crafting table over there in the
direction that you're going if you need
to make better tools yeah yeah yeah yeah
I already got some iron and some uh Some
Coal yeah okay I'm getting some ass over
here mining stuff like a like a
boss no no don't help him deny him deny
him that claim give me the power give
him the
nothing I've Got The Power shut up Wade
hey actually wait do that again do that
again wait I've Got The Power do a
higher pitch I've Got The Power
higher louder and
sadder what's that from that sounds so
familiar vender says that when they're
all having his fake funeral
on I don't hear any
crying louder and
sadder oh God why did they cancel
Futurama what a I think it kind of ran
it course I I can't imagine what was
going through Fox's mind when they
originally canceled
it how they canceled Family Guy for for
two in a years or whatever like what who
at Fox is making these decisions holy
crapy you guys watch the
Simpsons just recy now I just dug a
hole I all your name t The
Simpsons a long time ago yeah no joke
but it makes money F yeah that's why
they by the CRA we're having two
conversations at once here confused put
it in I've got I've got coold too so
I'll go plop it in all right anyway yeah
I think Futurama's problem was that they
were cancelled so they were forced to
create they were canceled Rec canell and
re brought back so many times they had
to they were forced to create like
endings for the show that wrapped it up
and then they brought it back which was
weird cuz then the story got kind of
sidetracked and they rushed some things
that should have been
rushed how do we get out oh there's
water I'm currently stabbing to death no
car down where I was at like 20 minutes
ago
man I need help kill some chickens and
we've got a furnace there's there's no
animals around me yummy yummy kill
yourself yummy I'm not going to kill
myself no I'm dead serious you should
probably kill yourself wait wait where's
the uh crafting table is it this way
yeah I don't want to I mean I'm saying
it'll get you back where you want to go
oh yeah okay here it is oh God damn
it I have a sword no one cares is it a
wooden
sword it's Stone
actually
chest yumy do your do your pirate
Hershel I missed
that I'm back pirate Hershel is back we
y Snappers that only sounds like a
pirate where's the her the Hershel's
lacking there yeah come on what did
Hershel sound like e my name's Hershel
that might not be what Hershel actually
sounded like but it's all I know at this
point on his
back oh my God
oh my god do that foreveri is so much
better than that impression of pirate
hersel and you were a pirate
hersel I don't even remember what I
sounded like back then I WR hersel it's
been like a year since you were on Drunk
Minecraft was weird I've grown up so
much my voice has gotten so much deeper
my voice is so deep little steroids yeah
yeah for your bodybuilding oh yeah meat
and chicken over here or or
weightlifting he's been doing weight
lifted you guys aren't at the spawn no
no we're not but you know where it is
y Mor yeah we're over in this mine area
I got I've been getting only coal so far
but do horses give food uh no don't kill
it don't kill the pony oh there are only
horses and sheep and I really want some
the pony eat it's blood wow jeez Wade
sorry sorry I got find cow want mistak
man there are so many
horses zombie can we a it's trying to
tell us something we need to like create
a horse stable uh we can't we haven't
even built a house how do you expect us
to build a horse table horse table is
top priority oh of course that is a
house okay hey a chicken you
chicken table is you killed the oh wait
no you didn't I just smacked the horse
he's fine oh God I was GNA we here at
Drunk Minecraft not Kone actual katone
what the hell is Kone we do not condone
animal cruelty no as much as I've played
this game like many hours as I've
vlogged in my life yeah where am I most
likely to find like chickens and and or
cows grass grasslands grasslands okay
welcome oh all right I see like five
pigs right now all right pigs come here
I think I see the pigs you're looking at
I'm going to kill them
too we're going to have again she's here
I see her do you guys not see her I
don't believe you she's right there
who's what are you doing to me she's
took your she's up in the sky she's
flying
away Mark stop just seeing
things is going
on Shenanigans she com for me she's
throwing knives at me just making this
stuff help help she's gone all right so
what do you guys want to do she
disappeared all right I've got a bunch
of uh pork now I'm going to come back
and cook it so that we don't die of
hunger can you show your drink wasn't
I'm also going to get some sheep
wool and make a bed and I guess we
should start constructing a house huh
yeah we probably should should we make
it out of Cobble just so we can't burn
it
down waade what's that blowing up noise
waade what she was right
here what is she was right here wait she
was right
here where wait she was where did this
hole in the ground come from who tried
to blow me
up who tried to blow me up it was
freaking where are you I'm right by you
Wade I'm down in the mine and I'm right
by you above it I couldn't blow you up
from beneath you I wasn't you I don't
blame you I blame Latin she was
here I you know I learned my lesson I'm
leaving Latin alone she was here thanks
for the iron Bob swear oh whoa whoa whoa
leave me enough to make shears at
least a little we're working together
yumy I can probably murder you wool in
the chest but wait is our house down
there in that mine no where is our
shelter it's across I don't have a
shelter
but oh it's where we originally were
okay okay I'm just I'm not dying of
starvation it's a
miracle good yeah wouldn't want you to
die that one I am for three
me that's a uh it's cooking right now
you could just take it out okay I'll
just take it for free
about why did you put this hole here I
did it blew up okay it blew up
uh-huh I have a lot of coal let me shove
it in the
furnace do you guys remember where our
our structure was
no oh hey Mark the web
is wait did you hear lightning yeah
that's I did I did hear lightning
actually oh my God know what lightning
means right it's going to I found a pit
of like three Enderman and a creeper
that's meant for me she's building it
for me it's just naturally in a dungeon
no she's building it for
me paranoid oh for good
reason Yash Latin has look she doesn't
exist Mark okay why is my death
certificate in here I haven't died yet
Latin goddess does exist my death
certificate is in this chest guys I
haven't died
yet guys oh my gosh
[Laughter]
guys hilarious no it's
true J does anyone know what Mark's
problem is wait I'm looking in this
chest and and it doesn't say anything
about Mark death certific you're
with me you took it out of there no it's
right there you see it right there it's
right there nothing there it's right you
took it I saw you take it's in your hand
no that's my kill
you you I don't think that's going to
play yummy if it's in your hand oh he's
not kill me there's something seriously
wrong with him Mark there's no need for
that you guys are crazy he's just gone
crazy you guys are The Crazy Ones I
can't argue with that he has gone crazy
crazy I found a naturally spawned
Enderman and he's like oh it's a death
trap for me right behind me she's
putting TNT down I'm getting out of here
guys M just planted TNT right now that
was not
me that was not
me getting out of here screw you guys
comment how much that Mark isn't seeing
anything you guys shut up you guys shut
up you guys shut the f
up I'm getting away from you you're all
conspiring with her you all are part of
the plan yes we are all conspiring with
the madeup person who's trying to murder
you you don't know who ltin is oh you're
trying to tell me you don't know Latin
oh I know who she is not here she's here
here she's gone MK nobody has seen her
but you she was here she I saw
her I wish I was recording from my
perspective cuz then I would show you
that she was not in fact where you told
me she was she was here exactly she was
here she was
here okay Mark do you need a hug no not
from anyone sounds like he needs a hug
no I I don't mind we can we can talk
yeah it's Marky Mash right you guys are
like butt bues oh no no not not like
that I mean a heterosexual one-onone oh
I heard an explosion that's exciting
think or something where someone mining
down here there's torches yeah I'm
coming to help Wade hey there's a bunch
of coal on the floor
no no yeah I was down this way I was
down this way what did you guys down why
do I always get left by myself I just
blocked off an area with dirt cuz I
already went down there there's nothing
left down there yeah I'm I'm going to
get this coal and then I'll see what
you're talking about Mark are you still
going insane or what no oh Bob that's
convincing I'm not CRA when you come out
this dirt right here on the wall when
you came down yeah there's an Enderman
and a creeper behind this little dirt
wall so don't go in there is what you're
saying I'm standing on it right now
right somebody teleport me to them cuz
I'm a little lost where I don't have oh
crap God damn it I don't have anything
that I can stack to get myself out of
this hole I just dug that was bad
planning oh you need help no I just got
to I'll get some Cobble and then make my
way up serve a lordy what an iron pick
Wade is that I got one give me the power
teleport
me there you go oh I'm good but thank
you oh all you to do is dig one stair
out so how far from like the um the
where the meat and the iron was did you
guys
go um I'm across the river mine is here
no cross the river you you kidding me
you see her right I uh I see her she's
just hanging out Mark she's not doing
anything she was trying to kill me wait
you see her too she is holding some t
god the disease is
inec there she is she's there you see
her right Bob right confirming standing
she's she she's not doing anything
though you guys are just trying to screw
with me because she's not she was there
mark just calm I believe you now just
calm down Port yam Mash to where we are
cuz yummy is a little
lost yummy is completely inep at
everything that he apparently
doesy I don't have a good sense of
direction guys press like F3 or
something to open your coordinates or
okay yeah where Bob open your
coordinates tell them where it
is uh oh man that's a lot of numbers
Jesus uh we're at minus
681 yeah where's what's your what's your
ex oh God
750 plus 750 orus 750 - 750 someone P
themus 681 and 56 y okay all right oh
Jesus okay why why is the other one
right that's that's two-dimensional on
the ground see I'm going to go try to
find yamy mash and bring him back I saw
you yumy you're going in the wrong
direction I know you are wait I'm going
to- 681 right now okay well you were
going in the wrong direction when I last
saw get to minus 6 get to minus about
700 and we're in that area cuz I'm
mining right now and I'm at aboutus 700
I
see yep and I need to see all right so I
just need to make a shovel and dig
straight down or something no what what
are you talking about dig down we're not
underground I'm on the surface mining
I'm just moving around where are you
where are you I'm at -
700 you're that's only one of the
coordinates why oh uh
64 B hey oh you found him right here
yeah Jesus yummy we were please Bob
never leave my side again I thought you
and Mark were uh special friends yeah
super special friends like I'm cheating
you and here comes the fan art yeah yeah
buddy I asked for that draw fan art of
me Bobby Mash Marky Bob Bobby Mash Bobby
BBY Mash Bobby Mash I like it yeah Bobby
Mash every all the artists out there get
on that Bobby Mash right now there's
going to be no Bobby Mash pictures okay
No One's Gonna Get on that who who wants
to make a Bobby Mash picture my fans are
too reverent I think all my fans just
think that I'm really funny and they
would never do horrible things exactly
they have a heart all right now there's
gonna be somebody out there who's like
making that devil meme face they're
getting Yeah well yeah now I'm asking
for it huh yeah
yeah all right well you guys like really
deep in the ground no no okay we still
haven't even built a house yeah whatever
that's besides I'm trying to collect
Cobblestone to make a cobble house cuz
well guess what guys we're actually all
out of time so I'm sorry to say it's
been 20 minutes it's been 25 minutes
said we was going to we only had time
for 25 oh man we should make like five
hour episodes so what did we achieve we
achieved the limits of human Insanity uh
we achieved murdering each other for
goods um we achieved the bonding of Bob
and yummy mes into Bobby MH I think
that's a pretty good thing that's a
pretty good day I think it's a good day
to call it a day yeah good job guys also
I almost died to call it a day also
AR she's trying to kill me okay I heard
that one I'm tending to believe that
that was real she's trying to kill me
hey what's going on fine f on Mark do
you see yummy do you see do you
see where are you guys oh my God I'm
staying in my hiding
spot all right well there you have it so
thank you all so much for watching thank
you Bob Wade and yamy mash for being
here it's fun ah oh I'm good as always
we'll see you in the next video byebye
see you guys bye
[Music]